[Musica]
buonasera
la prima volta che sono entrata in un
cinema è stata in compagnia dei miei
genitori
avevo meno di 10 anni e per
quell'occasione tanto speciale mi
portarono vedere cenerentola il classico
disney
essendo passate più di 30 anni da allora
non ho tantissimi ricordi ma alcuni
pochi sono estremamente nitidi ricordo
per esempio che mi senti adulta seduta
accanto ai miei genitori in un posto che
reputavo da grande e che già prima di
accomodarmi sulle poltroncine di velluto
rosso polveroso avevo deciso che quelle
esperienze sarebbe diventata un ricordo
così come era successo quando avevo
imparato ad andare in bicicletta o stare
sott'acqua senza tapparmi il lancio per
qualche secondo
risi molto mi divertii e pati per la
sorte di cenerentola chiedendo spesso ai
miei genitori si fossero sicuri sicuri
che sarebbe andato tutto bene
volevo la certezza del lieto fine
ne avevo bisogno per accettare i
patimenti
allora come anche adesso nutrivo una
fiducia cieca nelle storie è nella
narrazione
e non mettevo in discussione nulla di
quello che mi veniva raccontato se una
donna né odiava un'altra solo perché
quell altra aveva la colpa di essere più
bella di lei
significava e le cose potevano andare in
quel modo e non c'erano risposte
risposte da cercare se una ragazza che
subiva ingiustizia angherie senza
ribellarsi e anzi mostrandosi sempre
amabile veniva celebrata per la sua
gentilezza e la sua pazienza significava
che erano quelle le caratteristiche che
avrei dovuto coltivare se è l'amore
romantico veniva descritto come il più
dolce nei finali il sogno che si avvera
significava che era così e se fossi
stata fortunata come cenerentola lo
avrei scoperto anch'io
la convinzione che cenerentola fosse una
ragazza fortunata ha abitato tra le mie
certezze per tantissimo tempo sia quando
non ho cominciato a farmi delle domande
sul modo in cui le donne in questo caso
le eroine venivano narrate
cenerentola quindi era davvero fortunata
aver sposato un principe era sufficiente
per ritenerla tale
la fiaba di cenerentola è molto antica
si stima che ne esistano 300 versioni
prima di diventare patrimonio di walt
disney infatti cenerentole stata un
racconto popolare di cui è praticamente
impossibile scoprire l'origine
infatti a seconda del luogo e dell'epoca
si adattava alle usanze locali per
esempio vi siete mai domandati perché al
centro della storia ci siano delle
scarpette minuscole se una delle qualità
di cenerentola è quella di avere i piedi
piccoli
probabilmente lo dobbiamo alla versione
cinese in cina infatti un tempo era si
usa era d'uso la pratica del loto d'oro
ovvero l'usanza di costringere i piedi
delle bambine di 2 o 3 anni in
fasciature strettissime che avevano
l'obiettivo di deformare le dita e la
pianta in modo che il piede non
arrivasse a misurare ma è più di dieci
centimetri
sottoponendosi a questa tortura che di
norma prevedeva le ossa rotte ma che
poteva causare infezioni necrosi anche
la morte
le donne dimostravano alla società di
essere docili e inoltre acquisivano un
andatura claudicante che rendeva loro
impossibile essere autonome queste due
caratteristiche la docilità e la
andatura claudicante le rendevano
particolarmente attraenti e quindi più
adatte adesso faccio trovare marito
una delle versioni della fiaba di
cenerentola più nota è quella dei
fratelli grimm in questa versione le
sorellastre arrivano addirittura ad
amputare delle parti del piede pur di
infilarlo nel nelle scarpette la prima
la luce e la seconda il calcagno e la
matrigna suggerire alle figlie questo
geniale escamotage per riuscire
nell'intento di diventare una
principessa
le due procedono con un coltello
tagliano le parti indesiderate e
principe che non è esattamente quello
che definiremmo un giovane
particolarmente arguto si rende conto di
essere stato ingannato e di non trovarsi
davanti la ragazza con cui ha ballato la
sera precedente di cui pare essersi
innamorato perché bene del sangue uscire
dalla scarpetta
questi dettagli macabri scompaiono
nell'altra versione più celebre della
fiaba che è quella di terrore che è poi
quella a cui si è rifatto disney quando
ha realizzato il lungometraggio
nella versione di perrault non ci sono e
non ci sono coltelli non c'è sangue non
ci sono imputazioni c'è il cenerentola
che è una ragazza orfana di madre che
viene tiranneggiata dalla moglie la
nuova moglie del padre ed alle sue
figlie di cenerentola non sappiamo nulla
però ci dice solamente che è bella e
dolce queste sono le caratteristiche che
possiate questa ragazza bella e dolce a
posto così quei piedi piccoli
se però la maggior parte di noi
conoscono cenerentola e perché nel 1950
walt disney mi ha fatto uno dei
lungometraggi animati più celebri della
storia
anche le canzoni hanno contribuito a
quel successo canzoni che sono
abbastanza certa ricorderete tutti la
canzone che si può ritenere tema del
film perché si ripete in ben tre
occasioni
e i sogni son desideri
io non credo che esista persona cui
presente o forse fanciulla nel regno che
non la fa piantonare io vorrei de
trovarne qualche verso litro di cantare
però sentirò gli uccellini nella mia
testa
i sogni son desideri di felicità nel
sonno non ai pensieri ti esprimi con
sincerità 6 fede chissà che un giorno la
sorte non ti arriverà tu sogni e spero
fermamente
dimentica il presente e il sogno realtà
diversa
cosa ci dicono questi pochissimi versi
riassumendo e semplificando una bugia
ovvero che se credi fermamente in
qualcosa quel qualcosa si avvererà
quindi la colpa in caso di insuccesso è
tua che non ha insegnato come si deve
non ti sei veramente impegnato e non
nella società che non garantisce a tutte
le persone la possibilità di seguire le
proprie ambizioni al di là delle
possibilità socio economiche di partenza
ma qual è questo sogno che rimane nella
testa di cenerentola cosa che desidera
cenerentola desidera in grande amore
normalmente guardando cenerentola ci
potremmo chiedere è una ragazza che vive
in una casa dove l'hanno resa schiava è
una ragazza qui però di qualunque nome
il nome perché la chiamiamo cenerentola
come la chiamano per prenderla in giro
eppure ce ne è quello che desidera
cenerentola in tutta questa situazione e
avere trovare il grande amore e noi lì a
sospirare si grande amore giusto cosa
c'è di più importante anche io voglio
essere bella dolce
delicata e minuta e aspettare che un
uomo minuti e si accorga di che
s'innamori di ma è al di là di
cenerentola che fu il primo mio contatto
con questo tipo di storia c'è la mia
infanzia ce ne furono tantissime nelle
quali una protagonista che di solito era
inadatta alla vita perché
impossibilitata a fare esperienza quindi
incapace di prendere anche le decisioni
più banali non desiderava altro che il
grande amore unica soluzione a qualsiasi
guaio le fosse capitato e grande amore
che solitamente aveva l'aspetto di un
ragazzo belloccio incontrato per caso
avrebbe risolto tutti i suoi problemi
vedendo queste storie ascoltandole
guardandole io non potrei fare altro che
assorbire questo desiderio indotto e
iniziare anche io a sognare il grande
amore e tutto quello che si portava
dietro
tanto per cominciare l'idea che
esistesse un sentimento che durasse per
sempre senza mutare poiché io dovessi
attendere e sperare vi ricordate
dimentica il presente attendere e
sperare senza fare nulla per cambiare
ciò che della mia vita non mi andava
bene semplicemente ferma aspetto che
arrivi qualcuno mi aiuti
e infine
che il grande amore fosse la tappa
conclusiva del viaggio è che una giovane
ragazza non desiderasse altro che
celebrare il raggiungimento del suo
obiettivo con una cherie con una
cerimonia sfarzosa e un voluminoso abito
bianco e più andavo avanti nella mia
vita più i desideri che la società mi
diceva che dovevo desiderare aumentavano
essere considerata da tutti bella e
attraente sempre anche dagli estranei
sentirmi protetta
facendo mia l'idea che il mondo fosse un
posto pericoloso è che io non potessi
calpestarlo da sola e inoltre alcuni
desideri divennero delle vere e proprie
tappe obbligate come diventare madre ed
essere poi gioiosa e grata 24 ore su 24
senza mai sentirmi inadeguata senza mai
sentirmi stanca accettando con un
sorriso il peso della genitorialità che
nella nostra società grava quasi
esclusivamente sulle mani sulle madri
per lungo tempo io ho creduto che questi
fossero i miei desideri del resto perché
avrei dovuto dubitarne di fronte a un
racconto così martellante così capillare
così potente alziamo le mani sia noi
siamo siamo inermi non possiamo che
credere che sia vero e anche quando ci
pare che non ci rappresenti
abbiamo timore che ammetterlo significhi
essere giudicate sbagliate o meritevoli
di biasimo
cosa succede quando una donna dice di
non volere un figlio e la maternità non
fa per lei succede che la società nella
persona di sua zia di un amico di una
collega incontrata per caso alla
macchinetta del caffè le dirette non è
così che lei crede di non volere dei
figli di non volere il matrimonio ma la
verità è che noi ancora capitata
l'occasione giusta
per sé anziché deve stare attenta perché
senza la retta a questi desideri
presenti il futuro gliela farà pagare
sotto forma di rimpianto
i desideri indotti non possono essere
messi in discussione
perché la volontà che ci porta a
scegliere altre strade non è considerata
piena e reale
è piuttosto che portare avanti una
posizione che ci dicono essere
un'anomalia a volte preferiamo rimanere
a smettere di ascoltare la voce flebile
che ci parla dentro e ha sempre
assegnarci ad ascoltare quella tonante
che arriva da fuori
decidere di non sottostare alle
aspettative di genere e forse il compito
più difficile che una persona in questo
caso stiamo parlando di donne ma vale
per qualsiasi persona possa affrontare
si si inizia facendo proprio un
principio
la mia voce ha valore
la mia voce ha valore e io devo fidarmi
di ciò che dice
può sembrare una sciocchezza una cosa
banale ma in realtà non lo è primo
perché viviamo in una società che non
accoglie e valorizza il punto di vista
delle donne ciò che scrivono creano e
dicono secondo perché siamo così
abituati a sentirci dire che siamo
esagerate pazze isteriche che abbiamo
preso l'abitudine di
riflettere sulla validità dei nostri
pensieri e di non darla per scontata
eppure sono proprio questi pensieri che
ci possono permettere
imboccare la strada giusta o anche di
scappare da una di scappare da una
sbagliata gambe levate
seguire la nostra voce non è semplice ma
è forse l'unico modo che abbiamo per
realizzare i desideri di felicità di cui
parla cenerentola
io
so che imparare a sentirsi non è una
cosa facile e molto più semplice
decidere di accettare un desiderio
preconfezionato un desiderio che ci
viene porto e dato però seguire un
desiderio che non hai proprio non
difficilmente porta alla felicità molto
più facilmente e causa di dolore e
sofferenza le persone si rompono franano
abbracciando un destino che non è il
loro e che sono convinte si è solo a cui
sono destinate io non voglio
generalizzare non amo farlo eppure sono
cioè cerca di poter dire che non esiste
famiglia nell'acqua magari risalendo un
po nell'albero genealogico indagando la
storia di nonne zie nella quale non ci
sia una donna che per seguire desideri
che non erano propri si è spezzata e non
è più stata in grado di far stare
insieme tutte le parti di lei
rassegnandosi a un'infelicità
indecifrabile e anche incomprensibile
seguire la propria voce e difficile ma è
uno sforzo che dobbiamo a noi stessi e
anche mi permetto di dire a tutte quelle
donne prima di noi che non hanno goduto
nei nostri stessi privilegi
donne che cosa desideravano non solo
sono mai potuto neanche chiedere perché
non sapevano come si facesse
non esistono desideri e che non siano
degni
di essere realizzati e altri che invece
lo siano va bene tutto va bene
desiderare amore va bene desiderare il
matrimonio con bene desiderare la
maternità quello che non va bene e dare
per scontato che sia così
quello che non va bene e che non sia
ancora chiaro alla società ea noi che
c'è una sola cosa che tutte le donne
desiderano e non è un principe che
risolva i problemi per quanto mi renda
conto
l'unica cosa che le donne desiderano
essere libera di desiderare grazie
[Musica]
[Applauso]